the holidays are about spending time
with those we love and as 2022 comes to
an end we thought it would be fun to
look back at some of our favorite queer
couples that have shown us the meaning
of Love is love to kick This Love Fest
off we need to talk about nisi Nash and
her wife or how Niecy calls it her
husband Jessica Betts now Nissi caught
everyone's attention for her Stellar
performance in Dahmer monster the
Jeffrey Dahmer story but her and Jessica
made her story earlier this year as the
first same-sex couple to cover Essence
magazine and they look stunning another
queer couple we can't get enough of
Kristen Stewart and her partner Dylan
Meyer while speaking with Howard Stern
in late 2021 Kristen revealed to fans
that the pair are engaged oh and she's
over the moon with the proposal like I
want to be proposed to and then she just
grabbed that bowl and made it happen it
was so cute yeah and when we caught up
with the actress at the Cannes Film
Festival this year Kristen let us know
that and when it comes to wedding
planning the couples eats half behind
schedule don't worry about it we're like
getting wedding rings we're just behind
we're just like way behind
now there are certain queer couples that
are Hollywood royalty and have set the
bar high for queer couple goals
including the iconic Elton John and
David furnish Sarah Paulson and Holland
Taylor Ellen DeGeneres and Portia de
Rossi and of course the kings of
Halloween Neil Patrick Harris and David
burka but there's a wave of nuclear
couples that we can't get enough of
including Rebel Wilson and Ramona agruma
I love Rebels so much Rachelle Stauss
and G flip as well as Ben Platt and Noah
Galvin who announced their engagement
this year there's just so many queer
couples in Hollywood that are showing
all of us that love is love and don't we
just love to see it here's to more out
and proud celeb couples in 2023
hey thanks for watching ET Canada if you
want more queer entertainment news and
exclusive interviews be sure to
subscribe and check out these videos